[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
this [ __ ] dave chappelle thing's
crazy uh last night i guess it was
someone attacked him at the hollywood
bowl he's fine
i checked in with him today he's
laughing about it
he's uh in good spirits he was there's a
video actually he was laughing like
right afterwards yeah because jamie foxx
apparently had a cowboy hat he jumped on
stage to help
jimmy fox with a cowboy hat jumped on
stage to [ __ ] that dude up it is just a
wild time man [ __ ] i don't know what do
you guys think about it so some people
are blaming will smith
okay where they're like oh this is will
smith's fault he normalized attacking
comedians and he slapped a comedian that
everyone cheered blah blah blah i'm like
i don't really think that has anything
to do with it
it's not it's his fault it's just people
don't do things because uh they're
normal they do things for attention and
will smith doing it got crazy attention
this is gonna get crazy attention more
people will continue to do it as long as
it gets the attention it's like the uh i
don't know if they said this about
school shootings or like
or
terror but they said the more the media
the more the media puts it out the more
they end up happening right like copycat
[ __ ] basically yeah because you get
attention from exactly and this kid's
gonna get crazy attention apparently
he's a rapper
uh oh that's yeah and apparently he has
a song called dave chappelle yeah it's
just such a weird thing man i think it's
good he got his ass beat though yeah
that preston should be set if you [ __ ]
with a comic on stage you will get your
ass beat the chappelle thing was so
scary this yeah right not scary but all
right no
somebody somebody ran on stage and got
their ass
whipped it's not scary
it's one of those things that need to
happen though right like by the way no
yes
no what do you mean no do you mean yes
okay
mike do you want people to continue to
think that they can cross that line and
break the barrier of entertainer and oh
no no we're on the same side yeah that's
my point there is a momentary confusion
well i don't know how you can get
confused there mike somebody getting
their ass whip sends a message out to
other people that was like you know i
was thinking about doing that but oh i'm
saying that i don't really okay we're
saying the same thing i'm saying it's
scary the person attacked dave in the
first place no i think uh look i think
that the the world
that we're in right now there's a lot of
lines that have gotten blurred uh and
sometimes you got to take a couple steps
backwards to take some steps forward and
i think that moment that we just
witnessed with dave is like fogging up a
bigger moment like dave just made
history at the hollywood bowl yeah he
sold over seventy thousand unbelievable
yeah yeah
and
dave went back after that and finished
doing the show didn't let that thing be
a big thing yeah quickly moved on from
it and got back to doing comedy and
that's what a professional does yeah
ultimately you know these moments of
improfessionalism should not break uh
professionals they they shouldn't shape
or mold the world that we're now being
seen or viewed in so i think it's time
to get back to a place of respect my
week's going [ __ ] great i just had my
last stressful gig of the year
all right now the rest of them i can
just [ __ ] have a good time and try
not to get tackled while i do my [ __ ]
jokes
i like that people are saying do you say
you worried now do you think it's go are
you worried as a comedian that things
are gonna happen it's like no
these crazy people only seem to be
attacking black comedians in los angeles
all right
now i am in los
angeles but i am as white as a bed sheet
all right
and i'm proud of that and you can't take
that away from me or else that's
reversed something or other i think
it's a double standard
um
why can't i be proud of my alabaster
legs
god knows i pay for it every summer
dude look how [ __ ] white your legs
are
i realize that dude your legs could be
president how did he [ __ ] get in
the hollywood bowl
with that
weapon i don't know probably there
weren't i don't know probably that's
what's that that's what's crazy to me
look at that [ __ ] arm yeah right
well he's a dick yeah people were saying
it looks like thompson girl when he
tried to dunk the box in his [ __ ] arm
that arm's broken by the way
definitely
that arm's [ __ ] there is also like the
way they led him into the um the like
when he got into the actual stretcher
you could see he's [ __ ] it's so funny
you can tell the type of beat up that
somebody is when they're getting kicked
on the ground by different from
different angles by different people
it's a different type of like
beat up look
yeah you could tell that that left that
that left side of his face was the side
that was either on the ground or totally
like away from everything yeah i was
getting punched just everything's
swollen on the one side yeah he's [ __ ]
that guy
see me jesus christ i can't believe that
happened i can't believe they let that
guy leave without his oscar
what happened there they beat the hell
out of that guy man he was [ __ ] up
that i saw the chris browns on the line
i was like that chick
pretty crazy you know the guy had a
knife and he tackled chappelle and
didn't hurt him at all i mean dave
schabel does more damage when he hits
his knee with a microphone
[Music]
anyway so last night
i i had to host a show for netflix
um
i hosted this show during you know
having the big netflix comedy festival
here which has been [ __ ] amazing all
of these comedians that i've been
running into it's been such a great time
you know when lunatics aren't you know
charging up at the stage
jesus christ did they [ __ ] that guy up
no propelling like a g because he did
not get taken yeah
[ __ ] when wrestling you know when
they
shoot [ __ ]
back and yeah like and he had kind of
funny lines to say after it like in that
moment you're shook somebody runs up on
stage and apparently the dude had like a
weapon or whatever yeah like a knife
tonight did you you saw the actual video
i saw the video first of all dave
chappelle has good hips because yeah he
the guy
and he kind of turned with him he kind
of conclude him yeah he came a little
like keto
if you watch the video as the guy's
coming in he's coming in this way and
dave kind of like turns a little it's
balls too chappelle's a big boy bigger
than you think he is
well the guy's crazy clearly there's
something wrong with them
look at this and i mean there's just no
way to describe how
not expecting that you are when you're
on stage yeah
okay he just runs away
and then the comedian clicks in and he
comes back because he's like wait i have
to it's my mic right now look at this
guy running
oh my god that guy's never tackled
anybody in his life
no chappella almost almost makes the
clear out all the way yeah almost if he
just had a little training see that was
all an instinct
if he just had a little training imagine
if he just punted that dude in the head
when he went down yeah one of those
mossvidal knees it was a
it was a trans man
was that will smith
this guy jumped up on stage and attack
dave chappelle
let me ask you a question
as soon as that happened did they let
him go back to his seat
and laugh and sit next to his wife and
then give him an award no they took him
backstage they broke his arms and hands
so bad that when they carried out this
attacker on the stretcher
his arm is a video of it you can watch
it his arm is twisted backwards it's
like no human arm ever they they they
broke they broke his hands as his wrist
his arm
they beat her out of them
but at the academy awards the same exact
thing happened
and everyone came over and consoled
will smith
no one there was no jamie foxx no one
helped out chris rock nobody said
anything no one said throw this guy out
of the room
i told you i said uh you know after
watching it
chris rock didn't have a friend in the
room
no he didn't
because it was live television and
hollywood didn't know what to do about
will's methods listen you don't treat
will smith any different than they did
the chappelle attacker he didn't say
motive or anything like that they
haven't come out with any
crazy dude yeah people are trying to
draw it to the fact that there was
backlash with dave chappelle and his
trans jokes but they're it isn't
confirmed yeah i i i don't want to go
off i don't want to go off this very
since mentally yeah
yeah when you're that famous and you
have that many people there's going to
be a crazy person who's going to do
something enough there's actual footage
of getting tackled i don't like watching
it because did he get did dave chappelle
didn't fall though right i think he did
tumble the van but you'll see ladies and
gentlemen make some noise for hip-hop
history
he sucked at that tackle
well [ __ ] that guy yeah yeah [ __ ] that
[ __ ] i mean look at him
goddamn sunny asian he looks a little
bit but he also got punched in the face
a lot so
that's why
yeah
oh my god they're just a little bit more
close from the repeated punches in the
face we're not taking it we're not
taking another one well you're not
taking another why do black males hate
comedy why do black males hate black
comedy
why why black males hate black comedy
asian men hate comments black on black
comic crime yo black or black crime with
the comedy world man
this is disgusting watch out with them
jokes you get it too i'm just saying but
is it i mean well i don't want it to
happen anybody
we got two more shows left on this tour
infamous tour is almost over you got two
more chances in vancouver to get me
there is no
security in the front row at this thing
like there should have been someone
there that was uh scanning the audience
for [ __ ] weirdos they're ready to
sprint
crazy well we live in strange times man
i mean after the chris rock thing that
was one of the things i was worried
about i was like are people thinking
they're gonna start smacking comedians
now if they don't like what they're
saying yeah and what i'm thinking
or what i'm worried about
is uh you know people think that's
justified like people keep they keep
using the same things i saw an article
they said his transphobic statements
they're not they're not [ __ ]
statements they're jokes they're not
jokes that are transphobic either
they're jokes that feature trans people
they're not transphobic jokes his whole
bit in that last special that everybody
was mad at is essentially a love letter
to his friend that killed herself
because she was supporting him and she
got attacked on stage
the idea that that in somehow or another
is transphobic just because he's talking
about a trans person is [ __ ] crazy
what's the most unhinged audience member
you've ever had
um
i mean the worst one is when i got hit
with a buffalo wing i talked about that
that that happened that's the that's the
worst one that's a famous in the club
yeah i'm somebody in the club somebody
threw a buffalo wing at me um
but but here's like here's what people
have forgotten in stand-up comedy it's
always been the world of heckler
and comedian
comedian has always dealt with heckler
heckler has always shouted out things
because he felt that he could a
comedian's way of shutting that down was
to say things back it wasn't it wasn't
bullying it wasn't picking on it was all
done and fun we've now lost the sight of
the relationship of audience to comedian
and that line has gotten blurred to
where it's like well
i don't need to do this and like this
and i can stand up and make a point well
it becomes a hard case of well why did
you come yeah why did you why did you
buy a ticket yeah that was your want or
need so when i say we need to get back
to the place of respecting the
entertainer respect the craft if you're
coming come and have a good time and
enjoy the person that you saw if you
have no interest in that you don't have
to buy a ticket like imagine
you fifteen hundred dollars
or maybe more than that to sit front row
at a dave chappelle concert just to
attack him
the dude had a fake gun replica gun
whatever it was and he had a legit knife
like the hollywood bowl should be held
accountable for this guy bringing those
type of weapons into a venue like just
say the gun was real
this guy would have really killed dave
chappelle or injured somebody else who
was on stage they should like we had uh
dave chappelle jamie foxx busta rhymes
and numerous amounts of other people
that were there and also chris rock i
mean chris rock even came on uh at the
aftermath and said uh was that will
smith
like i'm glad they were able to make a
joke out of it nobody got to really hurt
himself for the guy who attacked dave
chappelle i mean they broke his arm bro
he kind of looked like woody from toy
story when he got finished damn man yeah
it is wild you think that this will
continue to happen oh yeah really for a
little bit yeah it's going to be a thing
oh [ __ ]
yeah better watch out i don't know about
you i'm a great fighter so i'll be all
right
are you at all concerned
i you know what i used to say even
beforehand was like i'm not trying to
hurt anybody's feelings so if you legit
don't want to be talked to just give me
a little thing and i'll move on yeah i
hate that awkward [ __ ] where somebody's
like yo shut the [ __ ] up move on and
then we got to do that and i got to
pretend i'm ready to fight you even
though we both know i'm not you know
what i mean yeah yeah so i'll say that
[ __ ] early on in shows like as i'm
teasing somebody i'll be like yo by the
way just thing if you don't want to be
talk to that's fine just let me just
give me one of these i'll move on so i
think it disengages a lot of that [ __ ]
but that is a thing i've had to think
about being five seven
for years doing comedy talking [ __ ] to
people shout out to jamie foxx by the
way jamie
james
[Applause]
make some noise for fox
whenever you're in trouble
jamie foxx will show up in the sheriff's
hat
turn the bike up
his hair was spongy
absorbent
listen i just want to say man i i've had
an incredible time this man is an
absolute genius we got to make sure we
protect him at all times man this is
what it's about for every comedian that
comes out here man this means everything
man you're a genius you're a legend i
enjoy myself thoroughly and we're not
gonna let nothing happen to you right
give it up
[Music]
you